i want to just talk quickly about
if you listen to the recordings from
heard uh that she made they were
intended to control the way the world
sees her
and uh as a victim and control the way
in which depp would see himself
you know if you're vulnerable and people
tell you over and over you're a loser or
stop hitting me even though he didn't
hit her you know you start to wonder
your own reality and that's very common
in narcissistic abuse they gaslight you
you know they say things and they'll
deny saying it
she was
setting him up for this uh the sad part
is narcissists like to ruin people that
they're with even they'll bite the hand
that feeds them look how good he was to
her you know
take the bogus
domestic violence claims out of the
equation
she she's like living in the penthouses
she's traveling around the world she's
with him on the island uh
she i'm sure being connected to him
somehow helped her career uh she's got
access to the best agents and lawyers
and
like
but if she's twisted inside and she's a
narcissist she's going to think about
how to bring them down
and then go on to the next one i'm not
sure how she got access to some of these
like elon musk or so james franco i mean
i saw a video on an elevator where they
were together it's bizarre it's bizarre
here's the point i'm going to go back to
this to anybody watching this you don't
have to be johnny depp to get tangled up
with someone like an amber herd it might
not she might not look like amber heard
but the personality is the same all
right and if you don't know what to look
for or you're not careful
you're going to bring somebody in you're
going to move somebody in possibly and
you're going to find yourself in a world
of hurt and we'd like to try to avoid
that from happening to you
um
all right uh
i don't know if uh
it's it any of your audience have seen
the movie gone girl it's a movie from
maybe
2010 or 2012. there's a ben affleck
movie
and yeah i haven't seen it
all right
he's married to a toxic narcissist and
she stages her own murder
i mean she uh draws blood out of her
veins and spreads it all over the floor
uh
you see a lot of the same similarities
in this case
completely emotional dishonesty
okay in this in the movie and i think in
this case
uh very calculating diagnosed
personality borderline personality
disorder sociopathic
she was a narcissist in the movie same
thing we're seeing here
always overreacts projects projection of
emotions is extremely exaggerated
same here in this depth case they've
heard just crazy but you listen to the
recordings and
she's nuts she's gone nuts and he's got
to put up with it why because he's
married to her because he's mad he can't
make an exit or get her out of his life
uh
i can't i can't stress this enough guys
like it it's it's very easy to march
into the slaughterhouse of marriage and
it's very difficult to untie that knot
and
it's it's even more difficult when
you're dealing with scenarios like
children or if you're married to a
psychopath like you know amber turd
you're you're you're gonna like there's
gonna be collateral damage on the way
out
a lot of it in some cases so
why invite that complexity you know if
you don't need to i mean
you could be with a woman just don't
marry her don't don't invite the state
into your life don't invite the state to
make decisions for you don't you know
don't invite crazy in your life it's
like i don't know like pay attention
guys right it's not only about the money
it's also about if you're married you
can't get her out of your living space
either that easily you can get thrown
out of your own living space and she
stays in it right yeah there's all kinds
of things that can go cases i've seen
cases where a guy will invite a single
mom who's crazy into a house that he
built
and he's lived in alone for a few years
and next thing you know she's getting
him out
uh it's not it's not good and then
you're on the hook to pay for kids that
didn't even come out of your nuts right
some some other guy's kids right you got
it
uh manipu manipulative with a lack of
remorse dishonesty
uh striking charm
that's that's uh amber hurt in this case
to a t
totally manipulated yeah you can see it
in the video it's clear as day
absolutely
uh all right so here's seven criteria
that i picked out
that describes these anti-social uh
people
violation of the law so she's bringing
yorkies into australia she's probably
done other things uh that were mentioned
in the trial
deceitfulness
very impulsive
irritability and high level of
aggressiveness i think the video
recordings to date in the trial show
that and she's hitting them and
she's just very irritable here's a big
one lack of remorse if you're dating
someone and they can never apologize or
see what they're doing wrong that's a
huge red flag
they're going to do something to you and
they could care less
that's a big problem
consistent irresponsibility
i mean
we've seen that so far in the trial
we've i've seen it in cases just
lavish living off of someone else's back
that's what's going on here
these are these behaviors are usually so
ingrained that the person accepts them
as completely normal and has no desire
to change them
that's that's what we see in this case
that's what you see if you get tangled
up with one of these folks
they are never wrong they just keep
doing the same things and you have to
take it because why because you're
married to them i've had cases
where
the woman will tell the guy
it's cheaper to keep me
then
and you know how do you think you know
that is just so cruel they know they're
wrong they won't admit it
uh but they know the law is on their
side so
there's um there's a few therapists that
i've talked to that have that have
overtly stated that they don't treat
people that are diagnosed with
narcissism because they're impossible to
deal with like
if if if a therapist won't deal with
somebody with this condition
why would you marry them
right think about that
because you're trauma bonded to them
right because
your uh your captain
saved them
and uh you feel responsible or
they say they'll change but they never
do
it's really ugly uh and if you've never
tangled with one of these people you're
not going to be able to believe it but
it's true
and they're everywhere so
word to the wise
do your homework and
make sure to the greatest expense extent
possible i know nothing's 100
but
i i just shake my head sometimes when i
see the things people do to themselves
so
don't do that
um
heard uh former
accusations again of abuse against her
former assistant she had a very monotone
dry assistant testify earlier in this
case
she paid the assistant 25 an hour
uh to and she abused her you know it was
a single mother it was just terrible and
you know if you see somebody treating
somebody with that kind of disrespect or
abuse it's just a matter of time before
it comes your way
trust me on this it happens all the time
she said that she was gonna donate seven
million dollars three and a half million
to the aclu who was gonna make her you
know their spokesperson for domestic
violence and three and a half million to
the children's hospital of uh l.a and
the testimony
uh contradicted that she did not uh
donate that kind of money what a virtue
signal eh totally being being the
chairman of a domestic violence
charity when you're like the [ __ ]
poster girl of it of a fraud
yeah
um she acts with the cameras if you
looked at any of the videos from the
trial
somebody took a picture of her blowing
her nose and she waited until she paused
yeah the photo yeah yeah
red flag red flag loves the attention
needs to fight
um
seeking compassion from the audience
most narcs you know they'll go to
anybody that'll listen to them woe is me
oh i've had such a tough situation he's
such a bad person
uh
horrible
sometimes they change their looks too
it's like a personality thing with narcs
they like to change the way they look
um
yeah it's just incredible what we're
seeing and it's such a blessing in
disguise because maybe it will educate
people
around
this is real i mean it happens all the
time and i'm telling you as a divorce
lawyer and someone that's seen this in
many cases
don't let that be you don't be deaf all
right
um don't be deaf there's gonna be
t-shirts mate don't be deaf yeah um
i i want to just talk for a second about
just a different subject
uh there was a posting done where jason
sidorkas served
his the mother of his child i don't know
if it's his ex-wife or not well she was
on stage
yeah right
uh and just clarify that
pr she probably refused service somehow
she lived in a gated community
or she wouldn't accept service by
certified receipt uh restricted mail
and usually sometimes
process servers don't get paid until
they uh perfect service so process
servers are like honey badgers they're
going to find that person and they're
going to get paid
so they figured out where she worked and
they had a server so she did it to
herself by refusing service
chances are he probably told the process
server
just server from home or wait till she
gets home she you tell the process
server
this is where she lives this is what she
drives this is what she looks like and
you and these are her hours usually but
if she lives in a gated community or she
won't open the door
uh and there's no adult there to accept
service depending upon jurisdiction they
just went to where she worked here and
here's how
here's how long drawn out that scenario
is is that jason was married according
to this wikipedia page from 2004 to 2010
to her and we're in 2022 right now 12
years later he's still dealing with this
[ __ ] and he has to serve her while
she's standing on a stage i mean you
know what
do what you got to do you know do
whatever you got to do to wrap it up
right absolutely now many custody cases
you're dealing with that stuff until the
child emancipates
which in most jurisdictions is the time
they reach the age of majority then no
court can tell them where to be
uh unless they have a special need
but so the kid turns 18 but in the same
jurisdictions you're still paying child
support sometimes until they're 21 or 23
until they graduate from college so you
have no control over where the kid is
uh
because no one can tell them and you're
right you know the kid this could be
going on for years
it's very unfair but
so if you're going to have children with
someone you don't even have to marry
them this could be you and the point is
don't let this be you
don't do that
vet carefully nothing's a hundred
percent but you can't imagine these guys
are drug they're brought back into court
or the mother of the child won't comply
with the custody agreement and the dad
has tickets to take the kid
to wherever on a trip on vacation
out of the country and she's got the
passport and they and the flight is two
days away it's just crazy so
think about it think carefully hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you